[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Noah Falstein.
I'm chief game
designer at Google.
And this is my 36th year in
the games industry and also
GDC number 28.
So I've worked on
a lot of games,
and it's taught me
to be a survivor
in this industry that's
constantly reinventing itself.
If you've been in
the games industry
for 10 years, maybe
even five, you've
seen how you're constantly
having to learn new skills
and explore new horizons.
And there have been a lot
of boom and bust cycles
over the years.
I put numbers on this
chart originally,
but it's actually
different for all of us.
But really groundbreaking
things-- things
like the first game consoles out
there or the onset of the world
wide web or
smartphones-- those kinds
of things come around only
once every decade or so.
And we're due for another
revolution that's every bit as
big and as important as those.
I think this is something
called transmogrified reality.
It's really a mix
of virtual reality,
augmented reality, and a lot
of other new technologies
and some emerging ones that
are finally showing promise
that they've been promising
to us for many years.
But specifically-- tomorrow
I'll go into more depth
on that at 4:30.
Right now, I'd like to focus
on one essential component
to what's going to make this
all work out-- Google's Project
Tango.
So how many of you have
heard of Project Tango?
OK.
Anybody have a developer kit?
There's a couple
of them out there.
He's a cheater.
It was just announced last June.
And it's a sensor
platform that's
designed to give mobile devices
a human-scale understanding
of their surroundings.
So they can basically see
what's in the room around them.
That means that now
a phone or a tablet
can know precisely where it
is while moving in 3D space.
It can sense the depth of
objects in a near view.
And it can also learn
and remember and map
the area around it.
So in 15-second chunks,
a little bit more info.
First, motion tracking it does
with six degrees of freedom,
using a wide-angle
camera and data
from high-res accelerometers
and gyroscopes
to follow the tablet through
space, back and forth, all six
degrees of freedom.
Second, it's got a
depth sensor that
can bounce infrared light off
of objects and surfaces that
range from about half a meter
out to three meters in range.
And it passes that
information back to the API.
And I'll be showing
a video of some
of that working in
tomorrow's talk.
Third, a Tango device has the
ability to learn and remember
its surroundings, and it
recognizes those areas
on a subsequent pass-through and
then refines its map each time.
So it gets an
increasingly better model
as it goes through
the same area.
And this has
tremendous implications
for business apps and also other
non-entertainment applications.
So for one thing,
consider how great
it would be for real
estate sales and rentals
to be able to scan in
a room or an apartment
and view your existing furniture
in the new place in real time.
But what about games?
Well, in the past,
new technologies
have enabled new game genres.
And I think this is going to
be no different than that.
All the while, while you're
working on these new genres,
you'll also be
learning about things
that are going to be really
important in this new mobile VR
market that's going to be a
big deal in the next few years.
So one way is to
consider that Tango is
a window into a virtual world.
There have been previous three
degrees of freedom solutions
that mean you can stand in
one place and sort of pivot
the phone or tablet around
and look into a virtual world.
And that's not bad.
But Tango lets you go into
the six degrees of freedom.
So you're not only
pivoting in place,
but you can move from
side to side, up and down.
And it knows where you,
how high off the ground.
And you can translate
and scale that.
It doesn't have to
be a one-to-one scale
as you do that for your game.
Or maybe even more
important, Tango
can allow people to quickly
scan in their surroundings, both
the boundaries of the
room and its contents.
And that'll let you
make games in places
where people actually
live, which I think
is going to be very exciting.
So for example, a whole
new genre of games
would be actual stealth games.
You don't just cause an
avatar to move around.
You actually move
stealthily yourself.
So imagine a spy game
where you're actually
moving through a maze
of laser detectors,
never exceeding one foot
per second of velocity,
perhaps watching yourself
mirrored on an Android TV.
Or, for more visceral content,
if you scan in your home
and have that be the
setting of a procedurally
generated action game or maybe
a mystery or maybe a horror
thriller.
And think how much
more immersive
it'll be when you stop
playing that horror thriller,
and you take the headset
off, but you're still
in the same room.
Interesting stuff.
So head-mounted
displays-- I'm implying
that we'll move into that.
I think that's a
logical next step.
And consider that a Tango
head-mounted display could
let the real world
through with its camera
or replace real obstacles with
virtual images to any degree
that it wants,
maybe even allowing
us to move untethered
through space safely.
But those are just
some of our ideas.
We're here because we want you
to apply for the Tango Program,
get a developer kit,
make your own blend
of the real and the virtual.
And Google tango dev
kit for more info.
We'll also have demos on the
expo floor starting Wednesday,
as well as Project
Cardboard, which
is really relevant to this.
And you can sign up to
buy a dev system there.
And thanks.
I can't wait to see what you
guys create for all of us.
[APPLAUSE]